you're more predisposed to being  chronically sick if you're obese big  pharma check maybe they'll be on heart  medicine huh check it's monthly maybe  their thyroid will not check  you know now you've got all this gender  stuff going on you think pharma doesn't  benefit of course they do that is a  lifetime guaranteed customer  for hormonal drugs  it just seems like everything that's  being pushed on people  has a benefit for pharma to then come in  and try to remedy that situation which  often times they don't remedy with a  drug that then not only is costly to you  but oftentimes has side effects that  then guess what they give you another  another drug  oh you had a bad that's my favorite you  go in and you're like oh i don't  something's going on they give you a  drug and then you go back and you're  like this didn't affect oh well you know  what stay on that one we'll give you  another one to counteract something oh  really that's nice that's 60 a month you  isn't that convenient